JF BASTIEN: Speed
matters for applications.
You could be doing
intense image processing,
complex scientific
computing, or just delighting
users with an immersive game.
Portable Native Client
brings speed to the web.
I'm JF, lead engineer on
portable code performance,
and I'm going to walk you
through how PNaCl delivers
the speed your users
demand and you deserve.
Going faster allows
us for better games,
makes users wait less when they
interact with applications,
and reduces the amount of
energy used by the device.
And as we all know,
longer battery life
means more game play
time and happier users.
Modern processors have a
treasure trove of performance
that often goes unused.
Let's explore a few
kinds of parallelism
that unlock this performance.
One source of parallelism
is at the task level,
where independent
work is conducted
in parallel on multiple cores.
This is achieved in PNaCl
through POSIX Threads, which
have been available
since launch.
Another type of parallelism
is at the instruction level.
Modern CPUs fetch an
instruction stream
and decode, reorder, schedule,
and execute instructions
using a plethora of
functional units, all
in a very deep pipeline.
This parallelism allows
the CPU to execute
multiple different
instructions at the same time
and is mostly free
for programmers.
Typically, this has been the
realm of compile engineers.
But it turns out that those
functional units are just there
waiting to do something.
And some of them
are pretty powerful,
yet usually go unused.
If you don't use
them, then your CPU
isn't showcasing its full power.
It's leaking power
instead, trickling
in small amounts of work
instead of going to sleep.
Let's zoom into one of
the previously mentioned
functional units.
Programming languages typically
expose scalar instructions,
shown here, as a stream
of four instructions.
The CPU loads one input data
per instruction and then
executes one
instruction to generate
one output data per instruction.
This is a scalar way to
do computation, which
gets the job done,
but it doesn't fully
use the CPU's capabilities.
CPUs have more than
just load, store,
and scalar functional units.
And that's where data
parallelism comes in,
where the functional unit
takes instructions and performs
the same work on
multiple sources of data
per instruction,
generating multiple output
data per instruction.
This single instruction multiple
data model is called SIMD.
There's still a single
instruction stream,
but multiple pieces of data
are fetched at the same time,
operated on, and multiple
corresponding outputs
are created.
The SIMD functional unit
can perform 2, 4, 8, 16
or more operations in
a single instruction.
Let's look at some code.
SIMD is usually expressed
through architecture
specific assembly
code or intrinsics--
SSC and AVX on x86
and NEON on ARM.
PNaCl expresses SIMD using
portable intrinsics that
are very similar to those
used on x86 and ARM.
And those intrinsics lower to
efficient code for each target
architecture.
You can see a great example
of PNaCl in action by taking
a look at Google+ Photos editor.
The team took existing photo
filtering software written
in C++ and were able to use
it directly in the browser.
Photo filtering typically uses
many forms of parallelism,
including SIMD.
And they operate very
fast on large images
by using fairly complex imaging
pipelines, most of which
are inscrutably
complicated to me.
But hey, they work
and they're fast.
Those complex pipelines
deliver beautiful results,
and allow users to add
some magical elements
to their pictures.
Using portable SIMD
intrinsics was minimal effort
on the photo team's part
because some of their filters
use a language called Halide, an
open source language developed
at MIT, which simplifies
image processing by decoupling
the algorithm from its schedule.
Sometimes it's more efficient
to compute images breadth first.
Sometimes it's better to
fuse value computations, use
sliding Windows or tiles,
or even a mix of techniques.
SIMD plays a small
but critical part
in using all of the
CPU's capabilities,
and Halide's biggest strength is
in expressing image processing
algorithms and mapping
them very efficiently
onto the underlying
machine, as shown here.
Applications which are suited
to Halide's computational model
should definitely
consider using it.
Here's another usage of SIMD
as well as threads on the web.
Folding@Home does protein
folding for medical research
to help cure diseases like
Parkinson's, Alzheimer's,
and cancer.
Protein folding is
incredibly complex,
and the research
greatly benefits
from the web's huge reach.
Merely using PNaCl over the
usual web platform increases
performance by two to
four X. Using threads
is a multiple that's roughly
linear the number of CPU cores.
And using SIMD is yet
another two to four X.
The Chrome browser enables
these great speed ups
through PNaCl with technologies
like threading and intrinsics.
That doesn't mean that
your development process
on other browsers
have to suffer though.
PNaCl offers a powerful
tool chain based on LVM,
and we support generating
PNaCl executables, as well
as JavaScript ones, so you can
fold proteins in all browsers.
This is done through pepper.js,
which relies on Emscripten.
While this fall back
comes with some caveats,
we strongly believe in
evolutionary improvements
to the web platform as
well as revolutionary ones,
such as what I've
just presented.
This completes our brief tour of
some of the latest performance
improvements we've
brought to PNaCl.
SIMD will be available in
PNaCl as part of Chrome 37,
to be released at
the end of August.
For more, check out
our site gonacl.com.
We're just getting started
with performance improvements
to the PNaCl platform.
On the SIMD side, performance
will improve significantly
over the next few
releases, and we'll
add powerful new intrinsics
as well as fun features
like auto-vectorization.
It's now your turn to use
all this power on the web.
Thank you.